[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's
chimichanga time with the news today
that Ryan Reynolds has met with Marvel
Studios to discuss the future of
Deadpool this comes hot off the heels of
yesterday's announcement by venom
director Ruben Fleischer who said that
spider-man in bed and will be meeting in
a crossover at some point in the
not-too-distant future
ever since Disney's acquisition of 20th
Century Fox in which all of the x-men
and Fantastic Four properties were
brought over fans have been curious as
to whether Ryan Reynolds version of the
character will be in the MCU due to his
bad language in over-the-top violence
however it looks like the wheels are in
motion with Reynolds posting on the 14th
of October the following photo and
caption audition for the role of Anthony
Stark didn't come even remotely close
with a nice man with the Taser escorted
me to the ground though Reynolds keeps
his tongue firmly in his cheek on this
one I think it's pretty reasonable to
assume that they were discussing the
future direction with the character and
Deadpool as a whole this is interesting
because it comes up the back of a
statement made by Disney CEO Bob Iger
who recently stated that Deadpool was
one of the big draws in the Fox deal and
that like the other properties he was
going to be a vital part of the puzzle
going forward Rob Liefeld the Deadpool
creator also reposted the image to his
Instagram account with the following
caption no feet of fine and fitting
welcome to Marvel hashtag Deadpool
hashtag Ryan Reynolds hashtag Marvel
hashtag no feet this is because Rob
Liefeld famously contour feet and yeah
it's just a hilarious caption yesterday
Deadpool right is Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick also said the following when
promoting the new Zombieland film Marvel
has promised to continue to let us play
in the aura at Deadpool universe and the
hope is that they will also let us beer
into the MCU a little bit as well and
play in that sandbox our feeling and
Ryan's feeling is that it's got to be
the right idea it's got to be great I
think once we collectively agree what
idea that great
is we'll be off to the races Ryan's
super busy we've got a lot of projects
lined up but we wake up thinking about
Deadpool and we go to sleep thinking
about Deadpool now obviously this is
great news and I'm glad to see that the
MCU is getting some of the big guns in
place such as the Merc with the mouth
and Behnam after looking at the face
full lineup though I was excited none of
the properties really had the huge wow
factor for me but with this it looks
like the gang will I'd class as the
a-listers in place in order to make that
universe even bigger now what Disney do
with the character will probably be a
risk but then Deadpool he's always been
a risk even the first film was only put
into production because someone leaked
test footage of it online and though
this was probably Ryan Reynolds without
the behind-the-scenes push I doubt that
this movie would have been put into
production the movie did go on to be a
huge success so it makes sense for
Disney to want to cash in on this and
make more money with the character
Deadpool can pretty easily slide into
any film I feel and he could even exit
it go off and do his own thing outside
of the MCU and return with no hassle so
I'm sure whatever gets announced is
gonna be awesome there could be a
team-up movie where the character
appears in a supporting role like Hulk
and Thor Ragnarok or the character could
get his own film with the release of
Deadpool 3 there's just so many avenues
to take and I really can't wait to see
what happens going forward now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
news and what you want to see in the
future comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure you
check out my breakdown of the news
that's spider-man and Benham will have a
crossover movie in the not-too-distant
future if you want to come chat to me
and toy either make sure you follow me
at definition whitey and if you want to
join my discord that make sure you click
on the link in the description below
you've got an awesome community and it's
the best way to stay up-to-date with the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there after this well so just want to
let you know that we're currently giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Deadpool announcement in
the comments section below
the one it's gonna be chosen at random
today on October the 15th so best of
luck to everyone who takes part and make
sure you keep your eyes glued to the
channel this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you